- [Voiceover] The sector
of a circle shown at left,
I pasted it up here, has center point O.
The radius of the circle is five,
so we see we have part of
a circle right over here,
so we have the arc AB,
and you see the radius
from the center to any
point on that circle,
so OB is five and the
length of chord AB is six,
and they've labeled that from
A to B, the length is six.
Line segment CO, this is CO, is
perpendicular to line segment AB,
and they've labeled that for us as well.
What is the length, L, of line segment CO?
One thing that might
immediately jump out at you
is we are dealing with a
right triangle up here.
If you have a right
triangle, if you know two of
the sides of a right triangle you can
use the Pythagoreum Theorem to figure
out the third side of the right triangle.
If we knew what CB was, if we knew the
length of segment CB,
so let me pick out an
appropriate color, I'll do blue.
Pythagoreum Theorem would tell
us that the length of segment
CB squared plus L squared...
Plus L squared...
I'll just do it all on
this. plus L squared
is going to be equal to
the hypotenuse squared,
is going to be equal to 25.
But we don't exactly know the
length of segment CB just yet.
It's tempting to say that
it's three, it looks like it's
half of the six, but we don't
know that for sure just yet.
What we do know for sure, is
look, if this is a right angle,
then this is going to be
a right angle as well.
These two things are
supplementary to each other,
they're gonna add up to
180, so this is going to
be a right angle, and if this
side right over here that
has length L, it's common
to both of these triangles,
so this triangle up here and
to this triangle down here.
Now the other thing that we
know about this triangle down
here is that AO is also going
to be a radius of the circle.
It goes from the center of
our circle to the, it actually
sits on the circle, kind of
on the outside of the circle.
If this is a radius, this
is also going to be five.
So what's the length of AC?
Well we could use the same idea.
We could relate A, C, L, and five,
so we can say just by the
Pythagoreum Theorem, the length
of segment AC squared plus
L squared is equal to 25.
When you see it in these
terms, you see very clearly
that AC is going to be equal to CB.
In fact, let me make that
a little bit clearer,
so we could say if we subtract
L squared from both sides
that CB squared is equal
to 25 minus L squared,
and we could write that AC squared is
equal to 25 minus L squared, and so these
two things are going to be equivalent,
so this is going to be equivalent
to that, right over there.
Now that is useful
because now we know that
the point C is at the midpoint of AB,
and so AC is going to be half of the six
and CB is going to be half of the six,
and now we can say with
certainty this is going
to be three and this is going
to be three right over there.
Now once again, you might
have immediately jumped
to that conclusion and
you would have gotten the
question right, or you could
have jumped to it a little
bit faster without having to
write all this math and say,
Hey, look, you know what,
I have two right triangles.
I know that two of their
sides are the same,
so the third side has
to be the same as well,
so this is going to be the same as that,
and so they're each going
to be half of the six.
That's all you need now
to actually solve for L.
We can say that three
squared plus L squared
is equal to five squared, or we could say
nine plus L squared is equal to 25.
Subtract nine from both
sides, L squared is equal to
16, take the principal root of both sides.
L is equal to the square root of 16.
The principal root of 16, L
is going to be equal to four,
and we see that choice right over there.